the White House says it was not told
about North Korean leader Kim jong-un
secret visit to China until after it
happened Kim made the unannounced
journey to Beijing this week to meet
with Chinese President Xi Jinping it was
his first trip outside North Korea since
taking power in 2011 and his first
encounter with another head of state Ben
Tracy is in Beijing with the importance
of the meeting Ben good morning good
morning Kim jong-eun is planning to host
a summit with the president of South
Korea this spring also with President
Donald Trump so if he had not even met
with Chinese President Xi Jingping
before that that could have been
considered a big snub now the Chinese
are calling this an unofficial visit but
what actually took place looked pretty
official if Kim jong-un is now trying to
appear like an international Statesman
China just gave him his moment the 34
year old dictators first meeting with
Chinese President Xi Jinping had all the
trappings of an official state visit kim
jeong-hoon even brought his wife resold
jus the two leaders met for talks inside
China's Great Hall of the People
followed by an elaborate banquet where
both men spoke chinese state media
quotes kim is saying the issue of
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
can be resolved if South Korea and the
United States respond to our efforts
with goodwill he also confirmed publicly
for the first time that he's willing to
attend a summit with President Trump
Kim Jong Un's relentless development of
nuclear weapons strained the ones close
relationship between North Korea and
China and led China to go along with the
series of tough us-led sanctions that
have squeezed North Korea's economy but
it was all smiles and talk of friendship
in Beijing president xi praised kim
jeong-hoon
for what he called positive changes on
the Korean Peninsula
David Kang is director of the Korean
Studies Institute at USC you know I
think both China and North Korea needed
this meeting what's clearly happening is
that Kim jong-un is engaging in a
diplomatic flurry of meetings to make
sure that he knows what everyone is
doing and that he's shored up his
relationship with China
now is Xi Jingping who invited Kim
jong-eun here which could be a sign that
China really wanted to make sure that
these two countries are on the same page
now interestingly enough President Trump
tweeted this morning that Xi Jingping
sent him a message saying that Kim Jong
moon is looking forward to meeting him
Anthony Ben Tracy and Beijing thanks